previously on model lifestyle
working everyday started to really hit
me hard and I knew I was getting burned
out
[Music]
[Music]
comes a point where you don't want to
stay in the hotels anymore you just want
to be home
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]
all right let's take a shower get just a
few hours of sleep and let's do this job
tomorrow today I'm doing a TV commercial
which is one of the best jobs that you
can get as a model because they usually
pay really good and sometimes you work
at a beautiful location like this one
[Music]
this is the directive today and she's
just busy explaining to me what I need
to do today alright so I pick up and
smiled in there and I think when we
start with each see hey guys we just
started the video this is the schedule
for today so we're starting with the
first scene they're busy but now check
it out this is how it really looks like
behind the scenes and this is the
commercial seams how so she got so so
how do you sound so alright and I'm
starving some lunch when I finish this
go to the next scene
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
TV commercials pays really well but they
can also take very long and most of the
team members are really tired by now so
I have a habit of doing certain things
that will keep them awake
[Music]
Tinka she asians finally we finished the
job and i was on my way back to
guangzhou but sadly the flight was
delayed by two hours
[Music]
I got back to Guangzhou at 2:30 a.m.
slept a little and arrived with my next
job at 9:00 a.m.
hey guys what's up
this is kind of the storyboard for today
machinima girl her name is Rita this is
where I have to do problem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
doing a photo shoot for the new Nubia
phone with Rita what's a lot of fun but
it was over quickly and I went straight
to bed
it is 5:00 a.m. and I'm on the road
again
so we're at Shenzhen today and it's
super hot it was like 35 degrees have a
look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another day and another job is done and
tomorrow will be a very hard day
the next day is here and today I'm
working for an e-commerce company that
needs to shoot over 200 clothes and
shoes
Wow yeah
put so many clothes now ecommerce
photoshoots in China really tests you as
a model because you have to stand on the
same spot the whole day to pose for
photos and also to change into other
outfits the photos are also usually bad
so you cannot use any of it for your
portfolio but it is a job and as a
professional model I will always give my
best in every job I get at the end of
the day I was exhausted but more jobs
just came flying in and I went from one
job to the other and boom
another job
another job
[Music]
oops that's not supposed to be in there
here we go another job
[Music]
and I stayed in one hotel to the other
[Music]
another hotel
in another hotel
[Music]
another job another job
[Music]
until finally I had my last job in China
[Music]
and before I knew it I was on the way
home to Pretoria in South Africa so this
baby right now he slid to South Africa
China still but this big guy here is
kidding me
anyway it's our life is like that
sometimes you see again in the future
sometimes not here we go
[Music]
ina color
okay guys
and here is the van to go take care me
anyhow Faye
so here we go
there was a pleasure to meet this big
guy really nice guy
okay so time to say bye thanks man
forever
I gotta tell him this
this guy and
I really gonna miss him anyway so we're
live I hope to meet him again someday
it's really hard lines like that
see you
one of the best and worst things about
modeling is that you become friends with
some of the most amazing people around
the world but you never know if you will
ever see them again
[Music]
you see enjoy your enjoy your family
your wife
guilty guilty thanks brother you too
oh hi guys he said
[Music]
the driver dropped me at the bus station
and off I went to the airport
[Music]
I checked in my luggage and waited for
my flight
[Music]
I have to take two flights to South
Africa and this takes a whole day of
traveling so we just landed in Doha I'm
gonna be around five hours overly and
then it's off to South Africa
next stop Doha is one of the most
impressive airports that I have ever
seen
[Music]
while I wait for my next flight I
usually edit some videos now I'm busy
with the video that you are watching
right now
[Music]
[Music]
finally I am back home and I cannot wait
to see my beautiful wife again
[Music]